we make the smooth segue to John Smoltz
the hall-of-famer MLB Network analyst
MLB Network will launch a new series on
Monday at 7:00 the sounds of baseball
Ben Scully's featured as the first voice
the greatest calls and moments from his
play-by-play broadcast John how are you
at the golf course I am but I got a
camping story to tell you okay thanks so
it's not you know Woodsman camper type
scenario we had a 27-foot Kondos condor
as a kid motorhome and we would go
camping in the Upper Peninsula and we go
you know all over the place in it and
then we just detected that there was a
short in the electrical system and we
all knew it but we were out on our trip
and the rule was you had to have shoes
on because the metal stairs and the
metal handle if you touch it without
shoes you're going to get you know shock
so we all knew it I'm on the inside of
the motor home campfires right outside I
decide I'm going to jump from inside
with no shoes out missed the step but I
grabbed the handle and I'm getting fried
like stuck to the handle and my mom was
behind me and kicked me off the handle
out on the ground and to this day my mom
thinks that's why my arm was the way it
was wait father in a good way or bad way
good way yeah in a good way she thinks
you know that I developed a super arm or
something when I was 12 years old but
yeah that was that would say that was
weed no longer had the motor home after
that we had to get get rid of it but it
was my fault for jumping out there
without any shoes and but in the long
run maybe you know maybe it did help my
arms well that's it's kind of like the
natural with a wonder boy the bass
zactly yeah exactly I do not advocate
that for any young 12 year old who's
trying to throw 90 all right we're great
to talk to you John we appreciate it
thanks for joining us all right give me
something optimistic about this baseball
season
okay the optimism is that they're going
to play all right all the negotiations
and all the bantering back and forth is
part of a deal that they have to work
out a million things so once they get
close to working out ten things you're
going to have in general I think an
agreement and then they'll play the
season out of this season I think you're
going to see some things that will
adjust for the future that will be a
benefit this is unprecedented times
these are tough decisions there's no
easy answer players are going to have to
make adjustments owners are going to
have to make adjustments but at the end
of the day I think they're going to play
the game and they're going to have a
unique opportunity to create some
different playoffs atmospheres and even
excitement and I think it's going to
trail into the next couple of years
you're going to see some things that
come out of it in my opinion that will
benefit teams that basically start out
the year and say okay you know what we
don't have a chance to win so we're
going to build for the future but with
extra playoff spots I think that
eliminates half the teams from doing
that I think it creates a better
opportunity to see more cities have a
chance to compete in the playoffs
yeah you're gonna go from ten to
fourteen teams for the playoffs if they
have it this year and I guess they're on
the books for next year I mentioned if
I'm a pitcher John I have some
trepidation with a let's say it's 50
games scheduled how am I going to be
used and we've seen you know you can
steal a championship here or you can win
your division you're you know with 50
games if I have three really good
starters or four starters or do I add
even more where I keep everybody fresh
for the entire season
but I would just be a little bit nervous
about a you know being a pitcher coming
back with a shortened season in hell I'm
gonna be used would you have any concern
about that yeah but I just don't I and
maybe I'm you know I'm not up to speed
on all this I just have a hard time
believing it's going to be a 50 game
season ok I think that's that I just I
really do I think there's going to be
somewhere between you know somewhere
between 50 and 100 is going to be the
number because that seems to be the
numbers that are both back and forth 50
games seems low unrealistic from Stan
point of a pod they're going to compete
and get it you know ironed out but from
a pitching standpoint I think the
biggest thing that that will be an
advantage the veteran pitcher knows how
to handle the situation better than a
guy who just basically chucks it throws
it as hard as you can
those guys probably a little more at
risk but I think they're going to have I
would assume they're going to have
expanded rosters I think in the
beginning month you're going to see
caution with a lot of pitchers and
you're going to see a lot more pitchers
being used that's my opinion on how they
would handle that getting ready getting
arm shape ready it's not that big a deal
but getting game ready would be a little
bit more interesting to see how how
people handle it and then of course they
got to work out how long does the season
go and how far into the offseason then
then you're starting to deal with
recovery but but I I'm optimistic Dan
that this thing is going to work out
we're going to play baseball it's going
to be unique it's going to be different
you know they're going to hear sounds in
the stadium that you never heard before
as a player you're going to have to get
used to that because it seems like
there's not going to be a lot of crowd
or any crowd at all throughout most of
the season but what are those sounds
were going to hear that we weren't privy
to before well I can speak from
experience when the Atlanta Braves when
I broke in I could hear the lights
buzzing I could hear the vendors saying
how bad I was I could hear every single
thing it's going to be more like back to
your youth days of tournaments where the
echoes and the sounds are just not used
to because it gets drowned out by the
crowd and you know from your gonna hear
everything the players say so it's going
to be it could be pretty unique to hear
some yelling some tearing or whatever
that's going on or some bantering back
and forth so that part will take a
little while to get used to believe it
or not when you're on the mound and
you're focused on getting out there's a
roar a dull roar but there's a buzz and
you're you're trying you it's almost
like you know some people can go to
sleep with sounds some people can't even
begin to sleep with a sound it's going
to be different for different people and
how they handle it
these John Smoltz the hall-of-famer MLB
Network analyst of course we're
forfox as well you know I start to look
at what the game is now and when we had
the lockout before when we had the 94
strike-shortened season you know you're
just trying to figure out what the fan
interest is going to be like what what
is in jeopardy right now if we don't
have a season this year or is that you
don't want to talk about that
hypothetical no no I mean that's a real
question and a question that everyone is
having to deal with right now because
it's not a normal circumstance we're not
just talking about labor disputes that's
one thing to hire and then hard you know
it gets it's hard for people to get over
because they don't understand it's not
just about economics but it always boils
down to about economics right so no one
wants to hear especially in these times
about economics but if the games not
played that's a real issue that will not
go well for both sides that that'll be a
fan base that will really struggle to
try to figure out why they couldn't work
it out and that's the PR battle that
that both sides always have to factor in
and I'm sure our and that's why I think
when you hear you hear some of the
things that come out that someone could
be posturing that but I just really
believe that in the end of the day
they're going to get to a number that's
agreeable by everybody a game number and
they're going to play baseball and the
country sorely needs that they know it
you know 19 I was part of the strike
that was brutal from the end from the
end end point of we lost some fans
permanently we lost some fans for a
while and when you don't play the World
Series me and that is that's how much
those times and how difficult those
decisions were based on on the
circumstances and the negotiations that
a lot of people didn't understand and
there was no way everyone could go back
in that time you could not and should
not have tried to explain it because it
didn't matter it didn't matter if you
felt 100% or you were righteous into
your belief it didn't matter the outcome
was not going to sit well for players
and that that certainly is the way it
went back then well you had Cal Ripken
streak that people were interested in
and
back baseball then you had Sosa and
McGwire like you were in the middle that
Sosa McGwire pitching in the National
League like how big a deal was that with
that home run chase between those two
it was unbelievable from a standpoint of
look I was a younger player and in the
midst of that you know just how I felt
like in every time I was looking up my
mouth was open with just the leadership
and everything was going on but from the
home run chase everybody got caught up
in that you couldn't help but get caught
up in that and and certainly a lot of
people will point to that as how that
healed baseball or brought fans back and
got the excitement back I really think
and I'm not just saying this I really
think the outcome of this season is
going to create some very interesting
and exciting future negotiations for how
the playoffs could or should look and I
think you're going to see some teams we
reevaluate how they put their teams
together based on the opportunity to
have a couple more playoff spots playoff
baseball is great just like playoff
hockey you know basically any playoffs
is where the interest the attention the
adrenaline everything is amped up and I
think you're going to see this season
however many games are played the good
teams are going to be good you're going
to get a surprise team because of the
the situation I've always said you've
heard me talk about it before I'm a huge
huge fan of split seasons don't need to
go into all those details that now about
what that is and how it would look but
this is basically the version this would
be like a first half split season
because that's all the amount of games
you're going to be able to play this
year and you're going to happen you're
going to see some opportunities of teams
that had no chance leaving spring
training the lot the outlook was bad 162
games no way our roster complete but in
let's just say they do 81 or 82 games
every team has a legitimate chance based
on the schedule that they're gonna play
this year with maybe - you know 2 to 5
percent of the teams that are just not
ready yet nice job by you not wanting to
talk about McGwire and Sosa and giving
up homeruns perhaps during that did you
give up homeruns to those guys no
I think I only gave up one to either one
of them in my career I think you might
want to have that bid that stacked check
but I think it was only one at their
peak
you got Sosa McGwire
who would you want to face well Sosa was
a little bit more of a wild swinger they
both swung and missed a lot I would say
so so only because his generated power
was different than McGuire's generated
power McGwire look like he could sit in
a chair and flick it with those Popeye
arms and just you know out the bigmack
land he is he was imposing he sat up
there and you just you know he wiggled
that look like a toothpick he had in his
hands for a bat
whereas soso you just never want to see
him hop and if he hopped you were in
trouble because usually that that meant
the ball was going you know over the
fence but I had relatively good success
against most guys that would swing and
miss a lot obviously Bonds was not one
of those guys cuz you look at most home
runs too and so I don't even know why I
brought that up
I know but I was going to because I okay
put the audience on the mound as you're
facing bonds peak bonds what do you
think he bonds the strike zone looked
like it looked like a coffee cup his his
discipline was so unique and somebody
told me later I mean his eyes when they
did the test of his eyes so he could
track a baseball longer than most which
spoke to his discipline but when you're
on the mound you know you've got one
chance to get him he's not going to miss
a mistake and he's not going to swing at
two bad pitches when he was at his peak
and I challenged him a lot that's why I
gave up a lot of home runs fortunately I
never gave up the ones in the postseason
that that hurt me but I challenged him
we talked a lot he had respect for me
challenging but he knew that he was a he
was better than anybody who was on the
mound and you know from the standpoint
of trying to squeeze the ball on the
inside here's the I mean I mean I think
I've told you the story but I decided in
the playoffs when I was closing that I
was going to mess with his mind
I asked Greg Maddux what he thought
about this game plan he says yeah I
think it'll work and the mindset was I
was going to throw a pitch inside and
then throw a pitch really inside I said
I got to move his feet I never move his
feet I never make him uncomfortable and
then I'm going to throw one up and in
I'm not trying to hit him but I got to
establish the inside part of the plate
so I execute the first two pitches he
kind of looks at me because it's totally
different than the way I faced him I
threw one almost under the armpit inside
probably a foot in off the plate he hit
it for a homer 420 feet the ball didn't
hook we won the game and I came in and
Greg Maddux goes how'd that work for you
not very well
thanks for the insight and I never tried
to do that again it was it is single
most greatest homerun I've ever seen a
person hit because you've got to see the
replay it doesn't seem possible that a
guy could pull his hands in and not hook
the ball foul and then basically run
around the fence and run around the
bases like you know what I'm Way better
than you in your first season 1988 you
made six home starts for the Braves the
average attendance for those six home
games was a generous 9700 people yeah no
way either I'm telling you there was
less than 5,000 and a lot of those games
their accountant season ticket holders
it was so difficult to not hear and I
was struggling with you know
concentrating anyways because you're
hearing all of these noises and all of I
mean literally rag City because we
weren't very good and thankfully when we
started getting good the fans you know
you didn't hear the light buzzing you
didn't hear the beer salesman the
crackers the you know peanuts
it was it was unbelievable and that's
you're not going to hear those sounds
because they won't be in the stands but
you're going to hear you're going to
hear this weird quiet and echoing of the
bat the sound of the bat you know
hitting in the in the in the stands
where
nobody's gonna be it's going to be it is
going to be weird and I don't know what
it's going to be like for the
broadcaster's who are actually in the
stadium to be able to broadcast the game
that too is going to be a unique
challenge when you're used to all kinds
of noise yep John I used to go to those
Braves games I was working at CNN at the
time and we would start in left field
because the Sun would be honest and left
then we would move to Center and then we
would end up in right
just above Homer the brave and we could
sit wherever we wanted to with the
Braves and and you guys were a young
team and you could see that you were on
the verge perhaps of something but I
just remember going to those Braves
games and it was basically sick we had
the the beer vendor just sit with us
because there was nobody else to serve I
we were just telling we just say hey
just sit here and then that way you
don't have to walk around but things
have times in my first couple years
there I went to a small comedy shop in
Atlanta and 80% of the jokes were about
the Atlanta frame and early I started
laughs and then I realized it's all
about us it's like hey what kind of what
time can you can you you know this would
be a good year to start to paint the
seats they they rag dust so bad and then
altum Utley we turned it around but man
four or five thousand in the stands that
was a common place back in Fulton County
are you on the first tee right now no
I'm actually on the 16th P way up top
par 5 okay elevator can you can you tee
off because we've had really very little
sporting events can you can you tee off
just so we can hear that yeah absolutely
here we go around John Smoltz Hall of
Famer very good little dress I'm gonna
I'm gonna dress the ball yellow ball
okay and now here we go I'm going to
send this one about 310 with a little
fade
ooh oh that was good oh that was really
really good I'm gonna take you at your
word John yeah I missed the bunker
middle of the fairway I got about 220 in
on a par 5 I'm gonna check back in with
you a little bit later on today to see
how you're doing John a always great
thank you thanks for joining us and we
appreciate your time as always my
pleasure that's John Smoltz